[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, and thanks everybody.
Welcome.
Here we are post-coffee
break, so hopefully you're
all caffeinated
and full of energy.
I know I'm a bit nervous
myself despite this being,
I think, I counted it's
the 27th GDC I've been to,
and I think I've
spoken at the last 20.
So I'm curious how many--
it's going to crush my ego--
but how many people
here have heard
me speak at a
conference somewhere?
OK.
Well, enough not
to crush my ego.
But those of you
who don't know me,
we've got this wonderful
service that Google runs.
It's not a game,
but I think it's
like a search engine or
something, so go right ahead
and look me up there.
I'm the Chief Game
Designer at Google,
which is a wonderful title
my boss bestowed on me.
Let's not make too much of that.
I'm going to talk about
looking to the future,
and I'm going to do that
by looking to the past.
I have the advantage
of, as I've said,
being around for a very long
time in the games industry.
I started making games
in 1980 professionally,
and it really is
not so bad being
a dinosaur in the
games industry.
We have a lot
going for us there.
For one thing, if
you look back, there
was extinction 65 million
years ago, but some of us
are still around.
I'm going to look even
farther back than that.
540 million years ago, there was
something called the Cambrian
explosion.
And it was shortly, in
geological terms, just
a very short time after
multicellular life started out.
And within this
tiny amount of time,
it just spread out into all
the different weird forms
that you're seeing out there.
Pretty amazing
variety of, kind of
monstrous and pretty cool
science-fictional-looking
creatures and everything.
And then there was some sort
of event, maybe an asteroid,
nobody really knows for sure,
and many of them died out.
In fact, only one of
those many creatures
you see there may have been
the ancestor of all of us here,
and I won't even
go into which one.
It's kind of humiliating
when you see which one it is.
But the fact is that
eras rise and fall,
and evolution, we've had many
things go up and then go down.
And over time, it's actually not
that different than the cycles
that we've seen in
the games industry.
So what can we learn from that?
Well, you look,
first of all, at how
there were these
games that came out,
and they were very
popular for a while,
and then nobody heard of them.
I was involved in the arcade
industry in the early '80s,
and within a course
of just one year,
we had 90% of our
audience just go away.
It was really shocking.
And realize that this was
early enough that there
was this sense of-- I had
people say, see, this profession
you think you've taken,
it's a little hobby that
was hot for a while, and
now nobody cares about it.
And luckily, computer
games started taking off,
and the first Nintendo
came out right
in the middle of that hole
when everybody was saying,
oh, it can't possibly work.
And of course, things
took off again.
But, you know, consoles
have come and gone.
There have been waves of them.
Sega was big for a while and
got out of the console business.
More recently, it seems that
this is going even faster.
We had a huge wave
of social games
with 100 million people playing
on the same day for some
of these games,
numbers that were
mind-boggling to those
of us 20, 30 years ago.
The indie movement, that
is going strong now.
How many of you consider
yourself an indie developer?
OK.
So it's almost
half the audience.
And 5, 10 years ago, that would
have been a tiny fraction.
It's become a really big thing.
Same thing with mobile.
Mobile was a niche
for many years.
I had friends who were
struggling with it around 2000.
Smartphones came out, and
it just started to shoot up.
And it's still increasing.
If you look at the numbers,
I have to say particularly
for Android sales, it's
just amazing to see
what's going on out there.
And, of course, tablets are
almost a brand new thing
by game industry terms and just
still going up in a great way.
But that brings us
to the core of this,
which is that-- it is
a bit of a cliche--
but the Chinese language
character for Crisis
is made up of the symbols
for danger and opportunity
together.
And, of course,
it's pretty logical
when you think about it.
But let me break
it down in terms
of what's going on in
our world right now.
So a lot of dangers.
Being a dinosaur
is pretty exciting,
but you can end
up like our friend
here who's outside of
the Google offices.
And I have to be careful
about what I say here,
but I had a friend who just
told me about 10 minutes ago
that there's a cartoon
that explains it.
The reason that
the T. Rex ended up
having those really
tiny arms is that it
was an early version
of Google Glass,
and with all the
voice commands, he
didn't need to use those
arms anymore, and that's what
happened to him.
Hopefully, that's not true.
For one thing, I think--
well, we'll get into that.
But having big teeth is
kind of a good thing, too.
All right, anyway.
A lot of people are wondering,
is this the last big console
cycle?
Are consoles having
their last heyday?
And it's been interesting,
because the sales
for the big AAA console
games, the top one
keeps going up and
up, particularly,
when you look at the sales in
just the first 24-hour period.
It's amazing.
But lots of things get really
big before they go away.
A lot of people are
very nervous about that.
The social game boom, as I
said, we had 50, 100 million
monthly, even
daily, active users,
and that's been-- it's certainly
not dead by any account,
but it's a very mature market,
and it's a dangerous one
to try and get into right now.
Another dangerous
area is mobile,
which was really wonderful.
So many people-- even now,
you can make a Flappy Bird
and do incredibly well, but
usually it's the big companies.
The production costs
and values have gone up.
I just saw an
amazing presentation
from some of the Glu people
and boy, high production values
are going to be the norm
for a lot of mobile games.
It's pretty scary
for that as well.
And business models
are causing disruption.
Free-to-play really took
a lot of us by surprise.
Some people rode that wave up.
Others have been slow to follow.
Digital distribution,
same kind of thing.
Great for a lot of people.
Terrible for a lot of
brick-and-mortar companies
out there.
Rentals are causing problems.
And boy, imagine renting a
digitally free-to-play game.
It's the apocalypse
coming together.
So you never know what's
going to happen next.
There's also, of course,
this amazing increasing
range of hardware out there.
In my 35 years or so
in the games industry,
I've never seen so many
different types of platforms.
Everything-- well, I won't
even get into the range there,
but even as that's
a scary thing,
there's an opportunity
there at the same time.
We've never been
making more money.
As an industry,
it's pretty amazing.
And maybe even more
importantly than that,
it's never been more
popular and more widespread,
and I mean that both
in the global sense.
We're all over the world now.
There are tiny countries one
or two million population
that have three or
four game development
companies in them at this point.
Very common all over.
I just got an
invitation two days ago
to an African game developer
conference in Nigeria
this fall.
Just stuff I never
would have expected.
At least I think it's
a real conference.
Now that I say that, I
have to check that out.
We've also never been
so consequential.
A lot of the work that I
did before coming to Google
has been in the serious
game space, which is just
at the very beginning of the
tip of the iceberg of being
able to save lives, change
people's training, and the way
that they learn and just make
them happier and healthier
in many ways.
We've never been so
connected in so many ways.
Even sometimes almost
a neuromancer kind
of jacked-in thing.
This is actually from a serious
game project here in UCSF
that Dr. Adam Gazzaley got on
the cover of "Nature" with.
First time a video
game has ever been
on the cover of the
journal "Nature."
Really exciting stuff going
on all over the place.
We've never been on so many
different devices and screens
at once.
And that's really just an
amazing thing for those of us
who have been
around a long time.
And one of the
consequences of this
is that there is serious
analysis going on.
Analytics are something
that's really big at Google.
You've heard something
about that today
if you were here earlier.
There are some more
going on later.
And, of course, universities
are studying games and giving us
more information than
we've ever had before.
So really exciting time.
You have the danger, you
have the opportunity,
but this causes
a lot of anxiety.
Where do I go?
Where do I get this opportunity?
What's the right decision?
OK.
I'm not going to give you
that answer, not exactly.
But I'm going to talk
to you about, perhaps,
algorithms that
can help you there.
To survive and thrive in
times of great change often
has been the case of the
cliche with the dinosaurs.
The little mammals
came out there,
and we and so many
other ecological niches
were colonized by that result.
That's kind of a truism of
the way evolution works.
Being flexible and
embracing change,
moving into these
new areas is often
a powerful winning strategy.
Certainly, there are a lot
of the biggest companies
out there today that have
done that either a long time
ago or even quite recently.
You think of
companies like King,
for example, that seemingly
came out of nowhere
and now are incredibly
popular just because they
got into the right niche in the
right way at the right time.
And something that's perhaps
the most important takeaway
that you can have
from this whole talk,
I'm talking about evolution.
And that's just an analogy.
The reality is
with evolution, DNA
mutates over millions of years.
Changes are slow.
You can't choose
which DNA-- well,
except maybe some bacteria.
There's some
interesting ideas there.
But better than bacteria, we can
actually make conscious choices
about what game ideas to take.
What new areas to move in to.
Where to explore.
And I think that is probably the
single most important thing I
can tell you, is that you can
pick those ecosystems that you
wish to compete in.
And Google is here to
help you with that.
If any of you've been to
some of the presentations
earlier today, and I
see some familiar faces,
we've got some more
coming up that are
just great through
the end of the day.
You can see that Google has
an amazing breadth of this.
But that's something
you would expect.
I mean, think about
what Google's into.
We're known as a search
company, but we also
are doing all these
Cloud services that
have direct connection to games.
Fiber is spreading out and
getting higher bandwidth
into more and more households.
Ads are a wonderful way
to monetize and fuel
the development of your games.
And we're looking at
better and better ways
to make the ads more
effective for you.
And as a game
developer, I always
look to make it non-invasive,
so that it can actually
help the player, and
they can welcome it.
Mobile, of course, with Android,
we've been doing quite a bit,
but we're moving Android
into other areas.
We've got Chrome on the desktop.
There are TV initiatives.
You've seen Android
micro-consoles out there.
We've announced an
automotive initiative.
Just today, our wearable
API was discussed online.
Lots of new things.
Can't talk about
the next ones just
yet, but you can count
on Google for releasing
all sorts of really wonderful
stuff as it goes on.
So what's going to
go on in the future?
I can't tell you
about any one thing,
but I can tell you that there
are some solid suggestions
that I think will help you.
Being open-minded, because
it's hard to say where
the next hit will come
from, the strategy
that you need to pursue is
think globally, and not just
literally globally, but in
terms of the whole breadth
and depth of this sort of game
ecosystem continuum out there.
Look for blue oceans.
Look for areas that
are fertile, that
are opening up that
seem promising.
And also that seem
promising for you.
That each of you,
as an individual,
for yourself, for
a company you may
work for, for a mega
corporation perhaps,
there are all different
ranges of that,
but what works for
you in that sense
is where you are going
to compete effectively.
So I can't answer this
because the answer's
different for each one of you,
but as somebody who survived
in this industry since it
was radically different,
you move from one
thing to another.
And if you're open to learn
and change and thrive,
then you're going to do well
with that sort of thing.
Being agile and
iterative is also
a strategy that always works.
If you stick with something--
I have an artist friend
who had one way of art
rendering in the 8-bit days,
and he was the best
in the world at it.
Probably still is, because
nobody does that anymore.
And he moved out of
art because of that.
So if you want to
stay relevant, you
have to keep iterating and
move around as you need to.
So you diversify as much as
practical even if it's just
a little bit, but
not too much for you.
You don't want to become
a total generalist,
and yet, it's amazing over
time how many different things
you can learn.
So those are some
of the basic tips.
The last one I want
to leave you with
is don't bet against
the internet.
This is something that's been
driven home to me quite a bit
recently, is that it's
not quite pervasive yet.
There are places you can
go where you're not online,
or you're not online reliably,
like maybe at a crowded Moscone
Center with a bunch of
techno nerds next to you.
But it's getting
better and better.
And the very fact that you're
able to get online at all,
and that it's getting
better each year,
is something that is going
to continue as we go.
And finally, let
Google help you.
We've really been doing
a lot in this area.
I am a long-time game developer.
I can say from now,
an inside view,
it's amazing how much
Google is doing with games
and how involved and
committed the company
is to helping game developers,
and I'm looking forward
to seeing that continue.
So that's my extent
of my inspiration.
I hope you'll stick
around for an afternoon
of some great talks.
And we're rounding up with my
friend and boss R.J. Michael
at the end of the day.
Stick around.
Don't miss him.
He's always a great show.
Thanks very much.
This is how you can
contact me if you
want to get in touch
with me later on,
and have a good day and a great
GDC for the next few days.
Thank you everybody.
[APPLAUSE]